[Applaudissements]
merci camille combal et je tiens à dire
je suis bien à tous les semaines tous
les téléspectateurs que je sors camille
dimanche soir je pécho
on est très bon mais je suis obligé de
dire quand même que vous avez énormément
de peine à jean luc lemoine qui voulait
sortir avec vos dimanche au forum et non
je crois y aller tous les deux je
voudrais juste préciser à tous les
supporter du psg que camille combal aura
maillot de l'om a alors je vais vous
dire je ne sors plus camille combal
voilà c est ce que tu as le temps pour
une toute belle histoire sur le foot
comme alors on a on n'a pas le temps du
tout là où on verrait pas vraiment ce
que tu veux pas revenir parce qu'elle
est allé très très bien regarder c'est
très courte c'est l'eau à l'om qui
saison des problèmes de joueurs ils vont
ils vont en irak chercher un joueur il
va chercher un super joueur en irak pays
le plan qu à la commanderie chez eux etc
puis arrive le clasico psg om ils sont
menés 3 0 à la mi temps ils sont entrés
l'irakien lemay qui marquent trois buts
il ya 3 3 à la fin du match mais que
c'est une star il est téléphone à sa
famille fait ouais tout le monde me
connaît maintenant à paris et vous
comment ça va sa femme est sa mère à lui
dit ça se passe pas bien ton père il
vient de d'échapper à un attentat
ton frère il est à l'hôpital et à soeur
elle s'est fait violer dans une
tournante mais qui dit je suis désolée
je suis vraiment désolé très désolé
c'est toi qu'a voulu qu'on vienne
habiter à marseille
[Rires]
est terrible
on se dit on aurait dû rendre l'antenne
avait encore une militante est pourquoi
grave le drame en direct le grade
merci michel amat à brest avec 80 tous
les atouts de la france une foule si
moon et participe à la production de
films éducatifs en bas de l'écran vers 6
techno pour dans les amours
merci à tous demain
20h45 que si l'on voulait la grèce en
bas de l'écran
on pourrait rire avec je les garde